de los empleados de la fábrica de
turbinas de belford que pronto será
comprada por edf general electric
emanuel macrón anunció los dos
importantes decisiones pensadas para
impulsar la energía nuclear civil
francesa
[Música]
lo primero es ampliar todos los
reactores nucleares que se puedan
ampliar espero que en el futuro nos
cierren ningún reactor en estado de
producción la segunda decisión
lanzaremos hoy un programa de nuevos
reactores nucleares
es decir la construcción de 6 ep rd
flamand bill aún sin terminar que ya se
ha más de 10 años en cualquier
caso el jefe de estado ha prometido
decenas de miles de millones de fondos
estatales para apoyar a edf y a la
industria a pesar de sus compromisos de
reducir la cuota del átomo en el mix
energético francés con el objetivo de
hacer frente al envejecimiento de una
parte del parque nuclear francés para
aumentarle el suministro de electricidad
en 25 gigavatios de aquí a 2050 y
alcanzar la neutralidad de carbono
convertir a francia en el primer gran
país del mundo en deja de depender de
los combustibles fósiles en un plazo de
30 años una salida de las energías
fósiles que implica también un
desarrollo masivo de las energías
renovables con el anuncio en particular
de 50 parques eólicos adicionales en el
mar para 2050 sin embargo los
ecologistas denuncian el discurso del
presidente para greenpeace es manuel
macrón ha elegido un fiasco nuclear